hace un mes el gigante farmacéutico
francés sanofi anunció un retraso en su
vacuna contra el hobbit 19 ahora se ha
aliado con su competidor estadounidense
the fighter para incrementar la
producción de la vacuna de esa firma
vamos a trabajar con ellos en su empresa
alemana en frankfurt cerca de su socio
by un tec esperamos producir alrededor
de 100 millones de dosis para ellos
antes de fin de año empezando en verano
aguilar para xavi que la sociedad está
destinada a agilizar el proceso de
fabricación al permitir que facer se
enfoque en desarrollar la vacuna
mientras sanofi se encarga del envasado
del producto tras los recientes retrasos
en la producción de facer y astrazéneca
el anuncio puede ser música para los
oídos de los países de la unión europea
sin embargo se necesita la aprobación de
la autoridad sanitaria del bloque por lo
que nada ocurriría antes de julio la
cadena de producción de faster puede
tener la capacidad de producir la vacuna
pero no necesariamente de ponerla en
viales pero sanofi puede ayudar a cerrar
la brecha sin perder demasiado tiempo
hacia luz
y willie sanofi también está avanzando
con su propia vacuna la que espera tener
disponible para finales de este año